Freunde wir sind gerade in Amsterdam
angekommen und wir werden uns schon mal
ein bisschen kulinarisch einstimmen denn
wir sind hier um foodsports zu drehen
aber ich möchte auch wissen was die
lieferlandschaft von Amsterdam so zu
bieten hat deshalb schnappen wir uns die
liefer-app unseres Vertrauens und gucken
einfach mal was es so gibt ich werde mal
nach den besten Bewertung Filtern aber
wir gucken schon worauf wir Bock haben
das sieht schon mal gut aus direkt ein
paar 5,0 Sterne Bewertung Emilian
kitchen Restaurant Amsterdam ne
parlesisch und tibetisches Restaurant
essen die Bakery und Café ich suche
eigentlich nach so Sachen die es bei uns
nicht gibt so weil das ist der Sinn
davon wenn man reißt und das Ganze vor
einem Essens Hintergrund tut wir haben
hier sunny side da ist ein Kuchen da
gibt's Pelmeni chicken Zug hat noch
nicht das was ich sehen will das ist
halt übelst geil aber da hatte ich
überlegt dass bei food Spots mit
reinzunehmen das ist übelst geil das
sind so frisch gebackene Brote ich war
da schon in dem Laden es gibt mit beef
das gibt's mit chicken SATA Halloumi wir
bestellen dass ich will das Essen
vielleicht steht es trotzdem noch mal
bei Fußball weil ich glaube ich liebe
das wir machen beef and Lattner und SATA
und Halloumi relativ teuer 12,50 € und
10,95 Euro aber darauf freue ich mich
jetzt schon unnormal das bestellen wir
und zwei weitere Spots suchen wir uns
noch raus schauen wir nach dem nächsten
Spot wir haben hier eine assai Ball viel
zu gesund scheiß drauf wir scrollen
weiter Schock die Teil Restaurants
gibt's auch in Köln
best Döner gibt's Onkel wir sind in Köln
ja wirklich boah das sieht geil aus
scheiß matters bei bei Tony loco und das
ist so ein Pizza Spot aber die haben so
eine Peperoni Pizza die so aussieht das
ist krank oder
tomato Peperoni Mozzarella with
Assassin's also auf der Kruste sind
Sesamkörner drauf das haben die für
Sorten Peperoni wollte schon immer meine
Barbecue chicken Pizza essen ich glaube
jetzt ist der Moment gekommen vielleicht
muss ich dafür noch Amsterdam kommen
also Barbecue chicken 18 € 36 cm größer
hat die Pizza so normale Pizza ist
glaube ich 30 cm ich glaube das Ding
wird Fett 18 Euro gib ihm aller guten
Dinge sind drei deshalb suchen wir uns
einen weiteren Spot raus Leute ich
glaube das endet nicht gut in Amsterdam
kann man so krank Essen und ihr kennt
uns wir werden es tun Bella storia
pasteria finde ich irgendwie auch eine
Wave ne was ist mir nicht genug wird nie
bestellen ich suche nur nach diesem
einen was ist mit mir macht Bro da sind
aber Hühnerfüße lol das sieht irgendwie
geil aus und Burger guck mal alleine
wieder sich da verhält wieder den in der
Hand hält so das Band ja das versinkt so
man sieht drauf
einfach ein Kranker double Smash burger
King hat aus Toppings peanut butter
jelly auf einen Scheiß Smash Burger
machen wir er hat nur Butter und
Marmelade drauf testen wir die Pommes
dazu ja komm müssen wir auch testen dann
nehme ich dieses Menü ja ja
21 Euro
Smash Cheeseburger
jelly orange Maracuja Aqua Monaco
26,80 Euro
Freunde ich kann dieses Essen
wortwörtlich nicht erwarten zu eurem
Glück ist es jetzt da Leute es riecht
schon so wie bei den letzten Mal als ich
das gegessen habe ich glaube das ist
schon trotzdem zwei drei Jahre her und
ich könnte nicht glücklicher sein das
jetzt in meiner Hand zu halten alleine
Verpackung ist fresh auf jeden Fall das
kam auch innerhalb gerade von 15 Minuten
an also ich habe das glaube ich das
erste Mal gegessen da bin ich einfach so
planlos herumgelaufen und der Hunger hat
mich wirklich so geplagt ich dachte so
ich muss jetzt etwas essen und dann bin
ich einfach in den Laden rein und ich
hätte es auch sonst nie ausprobiert aber
das sind die besten Läden die man dann
so findet das hier
ist unser satch also das Brot heißt
glaube ich das wird auf so einem
Halbkugel frisch gebacken die einfach
direkt rein
[Musik]
verstehst du jetzt ihr habt keine Ahnung
wie krank lecker das schmeckt das sind
orientalische Gewürze in einem frisch
gebackenen Brot unfassbar cremig durch
diese Soßen die da drin sind guckt euch
das einfach mal an dazu haben wir darin
frische Minze die würdest du den
Geschmack beschreiben das ist also die
Minze hättet komplett von der Seite
ich wusste gar nicht dass damit zu tun
ist dann hast du so eine Bolognese Soße
aber in der arabischen Interpretation
das ist eine Sache die muss man probiert
haben
lieferkonzept auch genial
sonst immer so drei Kilogramm Alufolie
eingewickelt du ziehst das Ding auf und
kannst direkt Wegschnecken das hier ist
jetzt quasi die vegetarische Variante
mit Halloumi man sieht auch wirklich das
ist frisch gebacken das Brot rein da
ganz anders Geschmacksprofil wir haben
den Sesam Halloumi viel frisches Gemüse
nicht so eine krasse soßeigkeit
Schrägstrich Feuchtigkeit wie man in dem
anderen hatte mir fehlen ein bisschen
die Worte für dieses Essen sowie das
erste Mal Sterneküche wo man sogar nicht
checkt was abgeht das sind so viele
Dinge die anders sind aber auf so eine
gute Art und Weise aber das ist eine
relativ kleine Portion jetzt gewesen
deswegen hoffe ich dass der zweite Spot
wo größere dass der uns ein bisschen
mehr gibt ich denke Tony 36 cm Pizza
wird jetzt unsere Bedürfnisse
befriedigen zumindest fast denn ihr
wisst was noch kommt weiter geht's mit
dem nächsten Spot 18 Euro Pizza liegt
glaube ich auch 1,8 Kilogramm Tony Logo
der verrückte Toni
ich hoffe dass auch seine Pizza verrückt
ist gucken wir einmal gemeinsam
Minecraft das ist wirklich was
Außergewöhnliches ne also so eine
Sesamkruste bei Pizza habe ich so noch
nie gesehen
Barbecue chicken bisschen Paprika drauf
und eindeutig natürlich eine
amerikanische italienische
Interpretation von Pizza Soße schicken
was willst du sein ganz wichtig
dazu
die Slice sind auch so richtig schön
groß ich habe letztens noch das Video zu
New York Style Pizza gemacht und es ist
nicht New York aber das ist Amerika das
ist auf jeden Fall geil
richtig viel Käse drauf ordentlich Belag
ich finde 18 Euro das ist halt eine
Pizza für zwei Personen ist auch
wirklich fair aber ich kenne das
Preisniveau in Amsterdam nicht dass er
sich die Preise nicht großartig
einordnen gucken wir uns diese Pizza
einfach mal an ein absoluter Traum der
cheesepool noch nie Barbecue chicken
Pizza gegessen noch nie mit Sesam Rand
das wird ein Erlebnis
boah das ist eine Kreation die heißt
zwar Pizza die hat aber mit einer
napolitanischen Pizza überhaupt nichts
zu tun und das ist nicht schlimm weil
das ist einfach geil also diese
Vielseitigkeit auch bei dem ein oder
anderen deutschen großen Pizza franchise
und du kriegst auch Barbecue chicken
Pizza ich habe noch nie bestellt aber
ich glaube die hier stellt
wahrscheinlich die ein oder andere in
den Schatten weil es ist einfach du
brauchst auch mal ein Stück was man auf
jeden Fall sagen kann jetzt rein
äußerlich ne wenn man ein bisschen zur
Seite schiebt die krass die sieht sehr
sehr gelungen aus also du hast ein
Volumen die luftig aber wenn du die
runterdrückst die kommt auch wieder
zurück in die Pose die ist jetzt nicht
so Steinhart weißt du auch von unten ist
die Pizza schön gebräunt hat sogar eine
kleine tigerung die ist knusprig die
saftig die Fett belegt da werden zwei
Leute von satt das ist geil
der riecht bisschen
ich probiere noch einmal diese
Sesamkruste ob ich die auch so weiter
empfehlen kann mit den sesamen Körnern
drauf und dem Dip an der Seite ist auch
das hier ein Hauptbestandteil der Pizza
wahrscheinlich sagen ich glaube jetzt
wird's Endstufe Smash Burger peanut
butter jelly das habe ich auch noch
nicht gesehen das Getränk ist in einer
separaten Tüte und ich glaube auch das
Getränk ist will Aqua Monaco orange
Maracuja
Bruder
30 € Lieferung für den Burger und die
Pommes the origine
und seine Pommes nicht so ist es in
meinen Augen vollkommen verwirrt
das ist so wie das sind auch schon geile
Pommes ne das ist schon die schmecken
geil die schmecken nicht Standard ne
gucken wir uns den Burger an oh alter
das ist re-shit Bro guck mal das ist
dieser Chip dünn Geschmack geschmolzener
Käse wow alter Schwede jetzt mal ganz
ehrlich ganz ehrlich was du auch
ansatzweise nur in Deutschland bestellen
kannst vor allen Dingen nicht in
Deutschland nicht in Köln nicht in Köln
drauf ne ich glaube ich werde sterben
guck mir mal runter alter
das ist Bacon Jam das ist so explizit
Content gerade
jeder der so so versautes Essen liebt ne
gerade innerlich innerlich am sterben
weil er das auch will diese peanut
butter jelly nimmt mich auseinander das
ist scharf das cremig das ist süß
die Pattys sind
knusprig unglaubliche Röstaromen die du
da dran hast
wir müssen nicht weiter reden das ist
der beste lieferberger meines Lebens
echt und auch einer der krassesten
Burger also stand sogar er wurde
geliefert man merkt natürlich dass die
Lieferung ihm nicht nur gut tut ne also
ich denke der ist wahrscheinlich dumm
knusprig wenn du den im Laden ist so
hast du so ein paar Verein crunchy noch
aber du musst da jetzt reingehen
Bacon Jam mit spicy peanut butter guck
mal dieses Band noch an das ist safe
auch selbst gebacken aber es ist so
unglaublich fluffig hey trotzdem die
Form nur das ist für die Zunge ich
greifbar es ist glaube ich gut dass man
das in Köln nicht bestellen kann weil
ich werde das die nächsten Tage die hier
sind werde ich vielleicht noch mal da
bestellen ich probiere jetzt noch Aqua
Monaco fürs mean geil zu süß passt gut
dazu mich überrascht nichts mehr der
Laden ist einfach krass drei Läden dies
allesamt in sich hatten drei Läden die
mit Stolz auch in Köln gerne offen haben
könnten ich glaube ich lieber Amsterdam
wir sind zum nächsten Video wieder wenn
es heißt foot Spots in Amsterdam die
fünf besten Restaurants die wir finden
konnten weil das heute hat auf jeden
Fall den Standard hochgesetzt hier seid
für dich vorgeschlagen